make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob and we are picking back
up again with deceased
and this is it's still like an amazing
story right like this is one you guys
need to get out and buy okay so so we
pick up with the last video that we did
right in the last video that we did
focus on the idea that the various
villains who existed out there
had basically recreated the amazon with
dr ivo right dr ivo was a guy who
originally created amazon and he's
essentially working for the villains now
amazo
is basically an android but he
essentially has the powers of the
justice league and he's one of these
guys where just one amazo can actually
take out the whole justice league
they have a whole army of them and one
thing to keep in mind the justice league
as we think about it is like the
traditional superman the traditional
batman and not to really knock on
jonathan kent
or damien wayne but there know clark
kent or
or bruce wayne respectively right like
they're just not on the same level as
their fathers and so what you're talking
about
is an army of of amazon's that's going
to be taking on what is in effect
a diminished justice league now for
oswald cobblepot right for the penguin
he's kind of impatient here he's like
dude you promised us results a while ago
right it starts to piss off ivo and he's
like look man like he basically like
activates a few of these robots he's
like look man
just one of these can take out the
justice league what do you think they'll
do to you
and understand these guys run on
programming if i leave off a decimal
point these guys will wipe out
everything on the planet right so i have
to make sure this is programmed
meticulously because remember the whole
idea of the villains is is to wipe out
the unliving but not for any kind of
altruistic means it's because once the
unliving are wiped out they can in turn
most likely turn the mesos onto the
superheroes take the superheroes out and
then inherit the world for themselves
right it's just kind of a
circumstantial world domination is
basically what it is now the other part
of that what we end up doing is we
switch over to cyborg and in reality
it's a little bit disappointing but it
turns out that the life equation is
inside cyborg and he basically
restructures or recodes his blood so
that the life equation is confined
within his own genome
the issue that i have with that is i was
really hoping we would see white
lanterns if i'm gonna be honest with you
guys i was really hoping we would see
white lanterns because remember all the
various superheroes who made it off
earth and are basically headed toward
you know who took off into space they're
with the green lanterns right like don't
forget the green lanterns are out there
and all the other heroes are with the
green lanterns the other heroes the
the surviving humans they're all
currently with the green lantern court
but regardless
what we end up having here is basically
like this kind of conversation right how
do they get this out of them like how do
they get the
the life equation essentially out of
cyborg
and then turn it into something that can
be used like synthesize it into a cure
that can be given to people well damien
wayne ends up having the idea to go see
swamp thing and the reason why
is not necessarily because of swamp
thing but because of alec holland
remember alec holland is the name of the
guy who became swamp thing and he was a
gifted biochemist right a biologist and
a biochemist probably the best
in the world before he became swamp
think and damien kind of hits him up and
says look man like we need you
right like we need the mind of alec
holland to help us solve this problem
right to help us solve this equation and
initially swamp thing is a little bit
hesitant not in the sense that he's just
like i never really liked alex so i
don't want to work with you but it's not
like a bruce banner incredible hulk
dichotomy it is one of these things
where he's like i can't do this on my
own what you're asking me to do
is not something that i can do myself i
mean i could but not in the short period
of time that you're looking for because
what you're looking to do
is to synthesize a cure as fast as
humanly possible and then spread it to
the world and while i
am incredibly powerful i'm not powerful
on that level
right and so what he ends up saying what
what damian wayne did is actually
concoct a plan
exceedingly fast and say yeah you're not
going to be doing this alone and the way
this works is
actually pretty genius right so you've
got swamp thing here you've got poison
ivy
you've got dr fate you've got cyborg
you've got uh detective chimp you've got
mary marvel the new 52 wally west the
the young black wally west you've got uh
harley quinn you have
all these people who are here because in
some form or fashion
they can basically help to synthesize
this via or synthesize this cure much
faster right mary marvel's got wisdom
the cure is inside of cyborg
alec holland is the mind of a of a
genius level
uh biochemist and biologist dr fate
who's there to basically unite the minds
of all the people who were here uh
poison ivy was a doctor of toxicology
harley quinn was a doctor of psychology
and medicine and wally west has the
fastest mind on the planet and then
literally tom taylor's like batman's
here
because he's batman and that's the only
explanation we get
because he's batman but essentially
they're able to to kind of turn this
into a cure that can be synthesized
right so it's only the first step the
next step is to actually
mass produce it right and so you kind of
get these diametrically opposing views
and the sense that superman sets up and
says now we can save them all
at the same time over in the layer of
the villains it's now we can wipe them
all out right so they're literally
creating two different memes to cure the
anti-life virus
one depends on wiping out everybody
that's infected and the other one is
about basically saving people
curing people who are infected and so
when the amazons start ripping across
right from their base of operations
spreading outward like a plague
killing everybody who's infected with
unlife literally just spraying them down
with heat vision this kind of switches
back over to the hero so you basically
say okay
now that we've got the actual cure we
need a test subject and initially
black canary or i guess really green
canary now wants to start with oliver
queen
but you end up having a scot-free who's
like no we should start with barta and
scott free plays this incredibly smart
right because dinah gets pissed off
she's like why should we start with
bartow right
why shouldn't we start with oliver and
scott freeze like well here's the thing
to think about see like here's the thing
to understand see if something goes
wrong
then barta is probably strong enough to
take it we shouldn't really risk oliver
queen's life i read that and i was like
well played scot-free
well played
and so once you what we end up doing is
transitioning or at least kind of
teleporting to a
basically a a life-habitable planet
that's out there by alpha centauri right
just some star out there and where
scot-free initially had barda tied up
she of course never left the planet but
she did escape her confines so at that
point they were kind of concerned like
where in the world could she possibly be
and then she comes crashing down on them
right like immediately attacks scot-free
now
in that moment superman grabs a syringe
and stabs it into into barta and then
it's just a ticking clock right like at
that point it's literally just
the clock's ticking down right seconds
and seconds and seconds like how long is
this going to take and bart
just keeps on going on the offense right
keeps on attacking and attacking and
superman's like okay the cure doesn't
work right like i've gotta kill her and
scott's like no don't hurt her and then
she snaps out of it right so the cure
works
the day is saved everybody the day is
saved right everything's copacetic big
barta has been saved
switch over to john constantine right
sitting in this room that only he can
access in the tower of fate constantly
being attacked by the cloak of ragman
right because it's trying to take the
soul of
of john constantine and then here comes
zatanna and she
is pissed right because she's just kind
of like what are you doing right like
why do you have a room here that nobody
can find
why do you have the wizard staff right
the wizard shazam why do you have a
staff in the sphere of destiny and
madame xanaduce crystal ball
why do you have all this right you came
back from this mission with jason todd
jason ty died right is this what he died
for us he'd agree to grab some just
stupid relics because from the
perception of of zatanna
constantine went through this whole
mission just for the sake of saving
these last bits of magic maybe not
really have anything to do with them but
just kind of collecting them you know
for his own personal interest because
that's really something that john
constantine would do dupe people into
going on a mission that only he really
cares about knowing they would die
but not really caring right not really
worrying not really worrying about it at
all the funny thing about this
is that with this door being blown open
and no one really being able to access
it
except for constantine and apparently
zatanna because nobody was really
supposed to know what was there she left
the door blown open right when that
happens constantine's like okay you have
no idea what you've invited here
anybody can find this place enter the
phantom stranger right phantom stranger
just comes
walking in to give the marvel fans
perspective imagine the watcher just
shows up
that's when you know things are going to
pop off and the phantom stranger is like
you stole madame madame xanadu's crystal
ball the path you're on
you cannot continue on this and the
response of constant is but if i go off
this path the entire earth is going to
die right i've seen the future i know
what will happen
the entire earth is going to collapse
we're all going to be destroyed
and there'll be nothing that we can do
about it and it's one of these things
where he's kind of being being chastised
by phantom strange right he asks uh he
has to tunnel like has he told you what
he's done
and she's like no and he's like well i
mean he took bragman's cloak he stabbed
ramakushna with the spear of destiny in
order to get the crystal ball and then
he imprisoned boston brand
in the cloak of ragman to thomas piss
she's like are you serious man like
these are allies right these are friends
people that we've fought along with for
years and years and years and you're
gonna turn on them like that like
why would you do that now if anything
all this shows is how
dark things are right how desperate
things are that this has to happen
now from there you have constantine who
literally starts laying into the phantom
strategy right like after what you did
to get yourself doomed for all eternity
right because we can kind of go with the
origin the phantom stranger is basically
judas and he's the one that betrayed
jesus he's like you're in turn
gonna chastise me about the decisions
i've made phantom stranger gets pissed
right since i'm flying into a wall and
then constantine brandishes the spear of
destiny which can kill the phantom
stranger and it's like go on dude if you
want to play this game we can play this
game i promise you will die
then suddenly out of nowhere etrogen
pops up right and etrigan's like
gone now oh etrigan and rise again the
form of man right changes back into
jason blood and says constantine
were screwed and he's like why and he's
like because trigon's coming well he's
gonna be here
in moments right in moments he's gonna
burst through that gonna burst through
the earth and all hell's gonna break
loose right hell
is gonna be coming with him you know
he's like and there's more on top of
that he's like of course because try
again invading the earth is not enough
what more could possibly be going on and
he basically tells them what's going on
with the amazo with the amazons
spreading across the world things are
getting
dire for the superheroes very very very
very fast
right because on one side
they have all the villains who've banded
together and launched this army of
amazos to spread across the world and
kill
all the various people that they now
have a cure for on the other side
they've got trigon who's showing up here
now let's be honest with ourselves
the biggest threat out of all these
things that we're facing right now is
obviously trigon
right trigon is like the biggest threat
they have to deal with right now but
it's one of these things where it's like
which one do they choose
if they choose trigon then the amazons
are just going to tear everything up so
there's not really going to be anything
anybody left to save
but if they ignore trigon and they focus
on the amazon there's not going to be
anything left to save right so like the
earth
all of them will all basically just be
cleansed and destroyed and that'll be it
because remember dragon's here because
he's angry over the fact that these
individuals who are infected with the
anti-life virus that they're not really
living but they're not really dead and
they technically
should be dead and because of the fact
that they're not dragon feels robbed of
their souls right he feels robbed of the
fact that he's not able to take those
individuals and bring them to his realm
right so he's basically just
showing up to kill them all to take
their souls right because they are in
effect
mostly dead right just not officially
dead and so from there they're like okay
like the heroes kind of band together
and say okay
so like the only real option that we
have here is to effectively
synthesize a cure and then spread that
cure around the world
to stop triggering right because the
amazons are governed by programming and
if the amazons are governed by
programming their program says they have
to kill those who are infected with the
anti-life virus but if there is nobody
infected with the anti-life virus
there'd be nothing for them to destroy
they would just stop what they were
doing
and just kind of free flow right they
would just stay there either that or go
back to their home base and just say
like all the unlife have been destroyed
basically because there is no one life
anymore so they killed the ones that
were there before all of them were cured
the only way to really do this the only
way to really pull this off is through a
combination of the flash and cyborg and
really the flash more than anything else
where he basically rolls through and
reads all these different books on how
to produce or how to how to duplicate
viruses or cures using that combined
with the plasma cells from cyborg's
blood the flash's abilities he was able
to basically create
three billion copies of the serum in
moments right probably you know an hour
or two
but like around that time you know with
within those moments like trident
busts out in paris right like
immediately explodes in paris all these
unlike come floating flooding towards
him and in
15 minutes everybody in paris is dead
right the entirety of paris is
completely and totally destroyed now i
know for somebody like trigan
you know this doesn't really seem like a
huge grandiose thing but this is kind of
the nature of dc comics you don't really
see things like marvel right if this was
a marvel story it would be like you know
trying to emerge
and then within two seconds everybody in
paris was dead like that's not really
that's not really realistic at least as
realistic as you can get when it comes
to comics right i mean we're talking
about a demon
emerging from hell pissed off because
people infected with a digital virus
aren't really dead right so how
realistic could we possibly be here but
in comparison between marvel and dc dc
plays a more quote-unquote realistic
tone with their comics than marvel does
right that's why things are a lot more
toned down
and not necessarily as flight of fancy
as marvel gets and so because of that
trigen you know just kind of makes his
way out of paris now with that being the
case
constantine goes and gets doc goes and
gets uh dr fate and says okay
i need you to see what's in this room
when dr fake goes into the room that
constantine always kept hidden he's met
by etrigan
and the phantom stranger and john
constantine putting on the cloak of
ragman
and that's when dr fate's like okay wow
okay this is bad like things are really
bad if you've got etrigan here you've
got the phantom stranger
who's basically this omnipotent
omniscient guy who
basically swears to never interfere like
things must be
exceedingly bad here and that's when
constantine's like yeah they are
i'm gonna need your amulet and i'm gonna
need your helm and doctor face like
that's not gonna happen man i'm not
gonna give you that
in that moment phantom stranger stabs dr
fate right just like plunges the spear
of destiny right through him and when
it's just kind of like why did you do
this he's like because constantine
showed me the future and you would stop
him from doing what needs to be done
right so
we got to take you out but the helm of
naboo which dr fate wears
cannot be just take it right it has to
be relinquished
freely he has to basically give it to
somebody and so constancy is like yeah
i'm well aware of that so he grabs the
spear of the wizard shazam puts his hand
to dr fate's head and then shouts
shazam and all the power of dr fate
transfers to john constantine
which he in turn takes the helm takes
the amulet and says
time to go right now enter zatanna right
she comes back in
like okay what's going like you just
took the power of doctor fate like what
in the world is going on here and
constantine's like i'm gonna go save the
day now the reality here that
of what tom taylor tells us is it
doesn't look like constantine's gonna
survive right it doesn't look like he's
gonna lift through this zatanna
isn't told this you know she's like are
you gonna be able to come back from this
he's like of course it's me why wouldn't
i be able to come back from that right
but he doesn't actually say
yes i'll come back he just says yeah
it's me right and so because of that
when he doesn't really give her a
definitive answer it seems to me because
she would try to stop him the question
to ask here if he's armed with a spear
that can kill a god if he's armed with
the magical power of dr fate which is
comparable if not more powerful than the
power of doctor strange if he's got the
cloak of ragman right which allows him
to use
all the abilities of anybody who's been
ensnared within the cloak is
all of that going to be enough against
the force like trigon
i don't know but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end
if you are new here to comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you